the allegations that william rag made on
thursday morning were extraordinary
explosive he says that some of his
conservative mp
colleagues in particular those who
potentially want a vote of confidence in
boris johnson have been subjected to
bullying and intimidation that may he
argues constitute blackmail although
boris johnson and some of his cabinet
ministers have said they have seen no
evidence for that now in a story first
reported in the telegraph and confirmed
in a conversation i have had with
william ragg he says that next week
early next week he's meeting with an
officer a detective from the
metropolitan police to discuss these
allegations although that does not
necessarily mean an investigation will
be launched why is he doing this well
partly because he doesn't want to be
bullied himself he wants this to be
taken seriously there's certainly over
the last 24 hours been a pretty a brutal
briefing campaign against him that is
not abnormal here in westminster but it
certainly helps substantiate
some of his claims about the
culture within this place he's also
doing this because of course he believes
that a crime or crimes potentially have
been committed and this is clearly an
escalation
in the battles that are going on within
the conservative party in westminster
battles that don't really seem
particularly sustainable at this point
and that is before we get to next week
where we are expecting that
all-important report from sue gray about
events and parties that have taken place
within government and in particular with
a number 10.